erste bett oder das zweite bett besser
findet und wenn dieses video 15.000
likes bekommt dann bestelle ich 1 davon
hey was geht ab märz willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut erstmal muss
ich mich natürlich entschuldigen dafür
dass jetzt wirklich vier tage kein video
kam mir tut es auch leid ich habe noch
immer ein recht schlechtes gewissen aber
ich war ein bisschen krank und
eigentlich sollte gestern ein video
kommen nur dann habe ich mein zimmer neu
eingerichtet also mein zimmer sieht
jetzt ganz anders aus sie merkt
vielleicht auch ich sitzt ganz woanders
das einzige was eigentlich auch gleich
ist es der schrank sonst ist alles neu
und das hat wirklich 13 stunden gedauert
bis ich fertig war ich habe auch am
ganzen körper muskelkater einfach weil
ich so viele muskeln gestern beansprucht
habe wie ich sonst nie beansprucht
ja ich habe mir aber überlegt es gibt
bald meinen ruhm zu meinem zimmer
eventuell schon morgen oder übermorgen
keine ahnung könnte aber in die
kommentare schreiben ob wir darauf lust
habt und heute geht es ganz stumpf
gesagt und mir zehn unnötigsten produkte
von gucci und zwar habe ich irgendwann
mal die zehn unnötigsten supreme
produkte vorgestellt und ich habe
wirklich jetzt gerade eine stunde im
internet gesurft und habe einige sachen
gefunden die ich echt witzig fand und
die werde ich euch heute gern zeigen
sind zehn verschiedene produkte
natürlich super günstig wie man das von
gucci gewohnt ist und ich will gar nicht
lange da wollten wir auf instagram let's
go
das problem ist auch ein bisschen ich
habe mir einen neuen imac geholt ich
hatte vorher immer nur ein macbook und
das ding ist so groß ich hoffe das passt
jetzt auch alles von den einstellungen
von der bildschirmaufnahme und so weiter
werden wir später sehen sich und sagen
wir fangen mit dem ersten produkt und
das erste produkt was ich gefunden habe
ist gucci schokolade acht verschiedene
stücke ich weiß gar nicht ich glaube ich
habe schon mal von gucci schokolade
gehört kann man in relativ vielen
hochwertigen schokoladen geschäften
kaufen gesteht jetzt leider keinen preis
sondern deswegen würde ich sagen ich
gehe das einfach noch mal kurz hier oben
ein
vielleicht finden wir ja noch was
anderes nein
wo bin ich denn jetzt hier überhaupt das
ist leider das einzige produkt wo ich
nicht herausgefunden haben wie viel denn
der verkäufer dafür haben möchte
deswegen machen wir ganz schnell weiter
mit
ja genau hier haben wir eine unfassbar
geniale gucci model also da kann man
halt alle möglichen flüssigkeiten rein
film kennt ja wahrscheinlich jeder von
euch hat sich auch für in einem
kindergarten wenn die mal wieder kaputt
war hat man halt ne neue im supermarkt
gekauft das ding kostet 235 euro nur bis
dir da frage ich mich wieso hatte ich
früher in der grundschule nicht sonne
gutes boxplay damit wäre ich doch
garantiert der könig der schule gewesen
nee ich hatte einfach einen für 29 90
jobs geht los an sich seine trinkflasche
natürlich was brauchbares nur wenn
irgendwann mit einer trinkflasche für
235 euro ankommen würde
den könnte ich nicht ernst nehmen also
da muss ich wirklich sagen da hört zwar
auch gut wir kommen zum nächsten produkt
und zwar habe ich was ganz interessantes
gefunden
ich brauche nämlich jetzt demnächst auch
hier in köln man verraten ich war sehr
sehr viel auto eigentlich war ich ihn
nur noch autobahn eher selten und ein
fahrrad ist natürlich immer bei seinen
guten wetter können wir das wetter gut
genießen und ich habe mir da schon 1
rausgesucht und zwar ist dass dieses
gute fahrt offiziell von gucci für
unschlagbare 15.600 dollar und das nur
weil wahrscheinlich zweimal diese gucci
streifen drüber sind gut wir haben hier
carbon räder und dazu gibt es auch noch
mit 900 euro gucci helle ja das ist das
fahrrad jetzt muss ich mal kurz den
gucci helm suchen hier haben wir den mut
890 wenn ich mir jetzt immer hier waren
die kutscher im 890 dollar
ja ja ich finde wenn man schon mal
15.000 dollar für das fahrrad auszug
kann man schon mal ein helm von 99
dollar dazu brauchen warum eigentlich
nicht so heute kommen wir zum nächsten
produkt ihr könnt gerne in die
kommentare schreiben welches produkt
euch denn am besten gefällt davon also
welches hättet ihr am liebsten schreibe
es in die kommentare
und ich habe hier als nächstes gucci
fußballschuhe her wir haben einen
fußballschuh von gucci für 374 euro
glaube ich stellt euch mal vor ihr spiel
wirklich sehr gerne im verein fußball
und im gegnerischen team wird ein
herumlaufen mit gucci fußballschuhen
also wer sowas trägt ja echt die
kontrolle über sein leben verloren ja
gut die fußballschule meinetwegen hier
so stark
aachen schuhe oder so ja auch wenn die
viel zu teuer sind meiner meinung nach
aber fußballschuhe muss man wirklich
nicht von gucci haben so willkommen zum
nächsten sache momenten nicht dass das
zeige ich euch auch noch wir haben hier
ein gucci schlaf set und das finde ich
wirklich sogar also dass feiere ich muss
sagen 210 euro finde ich dafür
eigentlich noch okay ich hatte es mit
eurer vorgestellt und hier habe ich mir
jetzt auch wieder was gutes überlegt und
zwar schreibt doch bitte mal in die
kommentare
ob ihr das erste brett oder das zweite
bett besser findet und wenn dieses video
15.000 likes bekommt dann bestelle ich
eins davon weil ich habe mir ein neues
bett geholt und das mit gucci bettwäsche
das ist schon echt richtig geil aus ist
auch schon groß also das wird eigentlich
genau passen genau hier 14 90 x 2 meter
das ist 180 x 2 meter 10 weil ich bin
halt auch 180 breit und zwei meter
großen also da bin ich mal gespannt
liegt an euch und als nächstes kommen
wir zu einem auto und gut sie auto wir
haben hier den fiat 500 by gucci da
steht hier oben bei gucci 14 trigos
jetzt dort abfälle italiens ja das ganze
kostet 15.990 euro wahrscheinlich und
diese drei streifen gleich 3000 euro
weniger das muss ich mal kurz google ja
gut da gut da gut hier 12.000 ab 12.000
als ist eigentlich ein knapper hier
steht wahrscheinlich auch noch irgendwo
vicky dran er hier vorne finde ich
eigentlich auch lustig hier haben wir
noch ein welchen findet ihr besser
schreibt in die kommentare den schwarzen
oder weißen wenn ich mich entscheiden
müsste würde ich glaube ich dem
schwarzen nehmen gut da haben wir hier
noch einen gutschein genau ich hab ja
auch keinen preis gefunden
hier oben haben wir sogar dieses gucci
logo in den lautsprecher integriert das
war nicht echt sehr faszinierend ist
aber jetzt nichts besonderes also wenn
man sich dann hier dieses geschieht was
wie ein schock für 670 euro
toilettenpapier das wahrscheinlich in
drei tagen leer ist oder 4
ach so da kann ich auch wieder einfach
nur den kopf schütteln da muss man
wirklich viel zu viel geld haben und
viel zu viel langeweile um sich das zu
kaufen
vielleicht kann das sein dass es 1980
produziert wurde und dann halt deswegen
so teuer ist adhs bestellt ihr
übersetzten zum beispiel auf deutsch
knöpfe würden angelaufen nicht im bild
ersichtlich verkäufer angeboten einen
rabatt auf zukünftigen eingaben
versandkosten 20 euro für ein
toilettenpapier dafür kaufe ich 5
packung toilettenpapier
was sagt ihr 10 dollar gebühr selbst zu
verpacken
es wurde aber zum geschenkverpackung
verschickt gut ich weiß jetzt nicht was
mit dir falsch gelaufen ist dass du das
bestellt aber selber schuld es kann eine
weile dauern diesen artikel fertig zu
machen kontaktieren sie den shop und
herauszufinden wann ist verschickt wird
gibt es wirklich eher schlechtere bewerb
wohl die jäger da denkst du dich auch
great deal und den osten piece is needed
cleaning auf einen luchs brandnew alter
so leute und eine sache habe ich
natürlich noch ich weiß nicht ob ihr
euch noch daran erinnern könnt ich habe
ja den supreme feuerlöscher nach gemacht
den wir damals zusammen gefunden haben
den hätte ich auch im internet bestellen
können für 200 euro aber irgendwie keine
antwort vom käufer bekommt deswegen habe
ich uns selber gut wenn jetzt wieder
durch gesehen habt euch nach diesem
video an und das gute ist ich habe hier
auch ein gucci vorher löcher gefunden ja
das war gar nicht mal so leicht aber wir
haben wir den budget feuerlöscher wie
teuer der ist das weiß ich nicht so
sieht er aus ist jetzt wahrscheinlich
auch noch einfach nur nach mache aber
fand ich ganz lustig wollte ich euch
auch noch zeigen wenn man hier weiter
krieg kommt maserati feuerlöscher ja
jetzt ist ja was haben wir denn hier
alles was gibt es denn hier alles für
feuerlöscher tiffany & co feuerlöscher
rolls royce feuerlöscher louie vito
feuerlöscher
dazu wird ja auch gern mal ein video
machen treibt sich die kommentare die
zehn unnötigsten louis vitor produkte
wenn er lust drauf habt ich würde sagen
das war's mit dem video
wenn ihr bock habe dass ich die
bettwäsche bestelle weil das würde echt
richtig gut zu diesem bett passen da
hinten hier mal kurz direkt danke dann
lasst es mich wissen mit dem daumen nach
oben zeigt auf jeden fall ist wenn man's
nimmt ab und wir sehen uns
wahrscheinlich morgen wieder dann
eventuell mit der kultur
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen tag
und ein schönes wochenende
haut rein